crisis in Greece the country remains
divided over the terms of a new bailout
package which the Greek parliament
approved last Thursday the deal includes
a painful mix of tax hikes spending
curbs and pension cuts as well as
opening shops on Sundays we spoke to the
journalist Philip pangalos in Athens yes
it's a big day today Greek banks will
finally reopen after three weeks since
capital controls were imposed it's going
to be interesting I expect to have some
cues in the banks today the reality is
that Greeks will still only be able to
withdraw 60 euros a day from their
accounts even though there is a
provision to let them withdraw a
cumulative 420 euros a week saving them
having to either go to the bank or to
ATMs each day so that'll make life a
little bit easier there are a few other
measures that are being introduced to
help restore normality people be able to
deposit checks not cash them in a bid to
allow businesses that have got checks
that a post-dated get them into their
bank accounts and there's also going to
be an allowance for Greek families that
have their children studying abroad to
send 5,000 euros a term abroad so that
will help them as well another
interesting point is is it'll be the
first time that Greeks can actually
access their safety deposit boxes since
the banks are closed and the key point
here is we've been told that people who
have safety deposit boxes will actually
be able to remove all of the contents
all the valuables and cash because there
were questions about that so I imagine
there'll be a lot of people queuing up
is thought to be more than 200,000
safety deposit boxes in banks across the
country people are being asked to make
appointments first to stop sort of a
stampede so we'll see how that goes but
the whole point of this is as we say
capital controls passed in place they'd
like to be in place for quite some time
it's more of a psychological move to
sort of allow Greeks the feel but
normality is slowly and gradually
returning and it comes on a difficult
day because of course today is the day
when these new v80 increases that were
voted on last week come into force we're
seeing a ten percent increase from
thirteen to twenty three percent on a
whole
the products mainly food products
process for things like sugar and cocoa
and even things like beef and mince meat
the other thing that's going up is taxis
already gone up so taxis will be more
expensive from today and that's
something that Greeks will feel in their
pockets and that's going to be put
pressure on the government with another
crucial vote this wednesday night
implement for the next wave of austerity
measures which include measures that
raise taxes on farmers and that's not
going to be very popular and it presents
a Prime Minister Alexis tsipras with a
bit of a headache and that he's got
concerns that he's passed this
legislation so far with the help of more
than 100 opposition MPs who are
pro-european as some of those opposition
MPs are concerned that their
constituents is especially in the
provinces won't be too happy that
they're voting in favor of raising the
taxes when we had 39 series are
left-wing rebels vote against the
measures last week so we'll see what can
happen this could be another crucial
week this week